bello i ragazzi e benvenuti a questo
nuovissimo video sono famiglie e oggi
siamo soli gol dopo 62 anni che non
faccio mi confronterò il mio nuovo
angolo di vodafone della casa che il
social busto che questo cabinato gigante
serve per interconnettere mi con voi che
potremo dialogare l'uno con l'altro
tutto questo è un po magico è un po come
se poi entra sta a casa mia un po come
se fosse la pasta porta di di harry
potter questa cosa fa quindi egiziano
sta puntata incredibile mio amico let's
go
vabbè ma
non è così che fate no no che lo
metti giù la no no non mario mario
d'amario
e novara giovanni destini si sono
innamorati con più di me ho più di
justin bieber di te posso farti una
domanda se mi è concesso perché se in
una discoteca
no no no è che cos'è lasko teca lì io
posso cambiare il colore alla pedana
fuori quando vedi a pensavo fosse un
frigo come frigo per terra lo tengo in
frigo a cedere guarda
non si vede quasi si vede ti voglio
tantissimo grazie tesoro una discoteca e
ci vediamo ciao ragazzi
non ci credo veramente
hai visto il suo lì per caso aspetta c'è
suri vieni niente te lo fa fare subito
arrivo aspetta che te lo metto la viper
pet sono sul giusto giusto ho fatto
giusto comunque piacere giovanni non
solo alessandra dalla sicilia ora sono
ben a dover studiare il computer grafica
grange lo so io quando è diventato il
cantiere un giorno
a giorno mi darà dimostrazioni quello
che sai fare e togliamo giampiero va
bene cosa quale
parlò po di tregua la fortuna e lo so
infatti milioni
si vede
america
salve
avevo finito
mariah to magna dei biscotti che devono
stava voto che devo farti temenos è
venuta male fatti vostri amici
mi
sento trovato cazzo veramente cosa vi
bovi scusa scusa lo riconosco e stai
bene io bene stavo bene se ti chiami
allo scusa ti chiedo sempre sono tanti
stai tranquillo e succede che io so
debole di cuore fatti in un gioco a
giochi spaventosi che sono a rischio
posso farti una domanda sul perché mi
sorge spontanea anche tre perché se in
galera non sono in galera aspetta a ok
un armadio quella sera va delle sbarre
di una stella ciao fratello bacio
perciò salve di dove sei di milano e di
dover quindi roma e piacere chi cerca
nessuno il troll ok arrivederci
ciao
che
la foto che dietro il telefono sta a
qualcuno
immagino sia qualcuno di un gruppo che
hip hop
si cose che senza neanche vederlo l'ho
detto dato per scontato io sto bene te
come stai bene bene apporta una grande
conversazione dietro ai le lucine quella
di stringerti nice che esplodono grazie
della foto spero di essere riuscito bene
ciao e stato un piacere
time to race
è esattamente questa fascia la tua
maglietta aspetta
come ti chiami lorenzo da un lorenza
volta solo uno ma poi va in conflitto
capite loren
loren e so pazzo e ci vediamo in giro ma
ma sei serio perché ci hai un
monopattino dietro è la prima cosa che
chiedono tutti quando vedono la
videocamera così effettivamente ci hai
un monopattino dietro non è proprio
normalissimo ok c'è stato l'ok da uno
però il monopattino incamera un po tempo
a 3 ma quando si è soli scusa loro e
cos'è che fai non va in monopattino
abbastanza bravo per mano ce l'abbiamo
monopattino chievo 1 pato non abbiamo
l'area meno clienti presenti alemanno mi
ami buonasera
portiamo temporali mio vero nome è anche
bene ma che bagno ciò questi non li
conosco chiedi chi sono questi non lo so
però liofredi che io ho stampato
solamente questi questo è l'ultimo
incontro guarda ma dov'è a romics
minutemen ad aquafan e un adesso che
siamo in tre a farla fa no tu devi farla
e stato un piacere di beccarti perché
almeno ci si incontra ogni tanto
perché non ci vediamo da tipo 34 anni si
soffermasse però come poteva dire
vedersi dai tranquilla allora quando
ripartiamo quegli eventi
facciamo una foto fatta bene perché non
diviso a metà ma come fai self che ho
già faccio solo quello è male che sono
tanto bravo e lo vedo perché sta
registrato a sorella quindi
la portano questo non so perché mi hanno
dato questa cosa perché adesso le farò
sentire una canzone
bene
e quindi ragazzi siamo anche oggi giunti
al termine di questo fantastico mico tra
tutte le serie del canale che ho portato
in tutti questi anni ogni gol lo sapete
tutti è praticamente la mia preferita lo
dico sempre perché mi permette di avere
un dialogo proprio diretto con voi
quindi non è solo io che parla una
camera ma io che parola camera con
qualcuno dietro che ha più senso
effettivamente questo sembra un pirla
però ho passato la mia vita
su questo io non posso fare a meno di
ringraziarvi perché senza di voi nella
mia vita non sarebbe questa quindi sai
ore a fare unico cioè veramente registra
il comico il di ore tant'è vero che
anche questa volta come tutte le altre
volte oltre che registrare questo ancora
a parlare con gente perché c'è qui
incontrano il più possibile io vorrei
ringraziarvi l'altra volta per aver
partecipato a questo video è grazie di
tutto quello che avete fatto per me
insomma grazie grazie davvero di tutto e
niente spero che mi sia piaciuto prova
il solito sentito il bisogno di un
documento mi piace anche alla risorsa
che compiuto dalla descrizione e noi ci
vediamo come sempre ad un prossimo video
bella ragazzi
[Musica]
no